[Musik]
vor den Paramount Studios in Hollywood
Streik der größte in der Filmindustrie
seit Jahrzehnten viele der Schauspieler
hier leben in Armut jetzt kämpfen sie
darum angemessen entlohnt zu werden
Hollywood ganz unten so kennt es auch
Christine McAllister früher beim
Fernsehen hat sie auch Geld bekommen für
Wiederholungen das war einigermaßen
einträglich aber bei den
Streaming-Diensten ist das vorbei
du wirst nur für den einen Tag oder die
eine Woche Arbeit bezahlt und das ist
großartig aber dann hört es auf und du
hast das ganze Jahr in dem du
vorsprechst und vorsprichst und
vorsprichst und währenddessen nichts
Verdienst
einige topfverdiener streiken auch mit
Filmstar Jack Black geschätzte 50
Millionen schwer Serienstar Bob
Odenkirchen gleiche Preisklasse das ist
Hollywood ganz oben Solidarität mit den
anderen hier die weniger Glück hatten
die Tage in denen ich finanziell kämpfen
musste liegen noch nicht so lange zurück
außerdem habe ich Freunde und sogar
Familienmitglieder den es nicht so gut
geht wie mir
und sie leisten einen großartigen
Beitrag zu dem was wir in Hollywood
machen und sollten so entlohnt werden
dass sie davon leben können
[Musik]
Christian McAllister konnte das eine
Zeit lang bei Jimmy Kimmel spielte sie
gelegentlich in Sketchen mit
und auch in TV-Serien hatte sie rollen
der Traum von Hollywood als Plakat da
oben an der Wand christin's Realität
unten wenig glamourös sie jobt als
Hundesitterin als Nachhilfelehrerin als
redenschreiberin als schauspielcoach
Person
Gelegenheitsjobs damit sie überhaupt
ihre Miete von 1600 Dollar bezahlen kann
die meisten Darsteller verdienen nicht
einmal die Grenze von rund 26.000 Dollar
im Jahr ab der sie sich
krankenversichern können
seit Tagen hat Christin diesen Brief und
traut sich nicht ihn zu öffnen eine
Rechnung von der Notaufnahme zu der sie
kürzlich musste die Kosten könnten sie
ruinieren sie legt ihn noch mal beiseite
als Künstler hat man nie ein Leben das
einfach so geradeaus geht es ist immer
ein Auf und Ab wir sind daran gewöhnt
keine Sicherheit zu haben
aber diesmal wissen wir einfach nicht ob
das auch mal wieder aufhört
vor allen großen Studios wird gestreikt
denn die streaming-plattformen haben die
Industrie auf den Kopf gestellt Autoren
und Schauspieler zahlen den Preis
deshalb haben sie Hollywood fast zum
Stillstand gebracht die late Shows
stellten die Arbeit ein Film und
Serienstarts verzögern sich
sie kämpfen um eine bessere
Gewinnbeteiligung darum dass auch die
Streamingdienste wiederholungs Honorare
zahlen die wollen außerdem mit weniger
Personal produzieren
und da ist die Angst vor künstlicher
Intelligenz das Darsteller gescannt und
technisch beliebig in Filme eingefügt
werden ohne einen Cent dafür zu bekommen
dominik perton ist ein Hollywood Insider
ihm haben Studio Bosse gesagt sie
wollten die Gewerkschaften aus bluten
doch die Streiks verursachten einen
Verlust von rund 5 Milliarden Dollar für
die kalifornische Wirtschaft so sind sie
zu Kompromissen gezwungen
es geht nur ums Geld niemand will Geld
abgeben niemand will Macht abgeben und
den Hollywood ist beides das gleiche
aber Tatsache ist die Studios verdienen
eine Menge Geld aber zwei Dinge erstens
will die Wall Street dass sie noch mehr
verdienen zweitens einige der großen
Studios vor allem Disney und Warner
Brothers Discovery sind geknebelt durch
Schulden auch die corona-pandemie hat
das verschlimmert also versuchen sie
natürlich nicht mehr zu zahlen
Hollywood noch immer thront der Traum
hoch über der Stadt weithin sichtbar
der Glanz und Glamour von Beverly Hills
ist magisch motiviert viele Schauspieler
ihren Traum niemals aufzugeben immer
weiter zu kämpfen für ihren großen
Moment
denn wer ist in Hollywood geschafft hat
lebt im Paradies
doch die Hölle ist nicht weit rund
75.000 Obdachlose mehr als irgendwo
sonst in den USA sinkende Gehälter
unbezahlbare mieten Los Angeles ist eine
Stadt der Extreme und Hollywood ein
Spiegelbild davon
man kann natürlich mit dem Finger auf
Hollywood zeigen aber ich würde einfach
sagen willkommen in Amerika die Kluft
zwischen Arm und Reich ist seit dem
frühen 80ern so viel größer geworden es
ist völlig wahnsinnig was Leute
verdienen es fühlt sich an als gäbe es
gar keine Verbindung mehr zwischen dem
Einkommen derer die Inhalte schaffen und
dem der Studiobosse das ist eine
wirtschaftliche Epidemie in Amerika und
beschränkt sich nicht auf eine einzelne
Industrie
droht darin unterzugehen sie fasst sich
ein Herz öffnet den Brief der ihr solche
Sorgen bereitet
2665 Dollar für die ärztliche Behandlung
Geld dass sie nicht hat wie willst du
das zahlen
ich ruf mal an und bequatsche sie ein
bisschen
und sie geht heute zum ersten Mal zur
Tafel sie wirkt verloren hin und
hergerissen zwischen Dankbarkeit und
Scham
zurzeit kommen fast nur Schauspieler
hierher
für Kristin ein Einschnitt ist es das
wert
ich wäre nicht die Person die ich bin
wenn ich keine Darstellerin wäre wenn
die Kunst nicht täglicher Teil meines
Lebens wäre insofern würde ich immer
noch sagen ja es ist es wert
die schauspielergewerkschaft und die
Studios verhandeln Christin hofft auf
einen guten Deal für die die in
Hollywood ganz unten sind
[Musik]